إصلاح خطأ أو عدم دقة هذه هي الطريقة التي
يعرّف بها القاموس التصحيح في
وول ستريت ، فهذا يعني شيئًا
مختلفًا قليلاً. تصحيح سوق الأسهم هو
مصطلح تقني يشير إلى انخفاض بنسبة 10 ٪
من أعلى مستوى أخير ، وهو أقل
حدة من سوق هابطة عندما
تنخفض الأسهم  20٪ الآن
قد يبدو التصحيح مخيفًا ، لكنه في الحقيقة
جزء صحي طبيعي من الدورة ،
حيث كان لدى sp500 أربعة تصحيحات من عام 2010
حتى عام 2017 وخمسة من عام 1990 إلى عام 2000
، وذلك لأنه لا يُفترض بالأسواق
أن تتنفس بشكل مباشر مرة واحدة في
في حين أنه مهم مثل إعادة ضبط السوق ،
فإنه يمكن أن يمنع ارتفاع درجة حرارة الأسهم
ويسمح للمستثمرين بإعادة تقييم
محافظهم ، ما لا يجب عليك فعله بالتأكيد
هو الذعر ، لا يعني التصحيح أنه
يجب عليك بيع جميع الأسهم الخاصة بك
، بل على العكس من ذلك ، يمكن أن يكون فرصة
لشراء تذكر أن التاريخ يظهر أن الأسهم غالبًا ما
ترتفع بعد التصحيح